some gamers aren't happy about how DLC
has become synonymous with expansion
packs now technically DLC can include
expansion packs but in common usage
that's a pretty crucial difference
between the two
DLC places the emphasis on smaller
individual extra pieces of contents
generally consisting of new gear a few
new quests or missions and cosmetic
stuff
comparatively there's quite a bit more
expected out of expansion packs which
traditionally use the framework of the
base game to pursue new gameplay or
narrative ideas my first experience with
expansion packs was with Heroes of Might
& Magic and the original Sims game where
developers would periodically release
meaty expansions onto store shelves
these expansions were huge with dozens
of hours of content which frequently
included totally different ways to play
the game like new factions playable
races and storylines for RPGs or a heap
of new campaign scenarios for strategy
games this hasn't all been left in the
past though Blizzard are still famously
rolling out major expansion packs for
Diablo Starcraft and World of Warcraft
which have been pretty successful at
drawing players back into these series
Starcraft 2 is just about to get another
one for example the game's first major
expansion heart of the swarm landed two
years ago and its second expansion
legacy of the void is currently in beta
testing mode these sorts of expansions
generally cost quite a few of your
dollars but for a game you're already
into they can be an excellent way to put
a whole new face on a title or franchise
without sacrificing the framework you
liked to begin with that said expansions
are certainly less prevalent than they
used to be and tends to exclusively crop
up to the more PC friendly to play games
like Skyrim civilization and XCOM DLC on
the other hand runs a broad gamut from
minor cosmetic additions like character
skins and extra weapons all the way up
to excellent
stories like The Last of Us is left
behind and Bioshock twos Minerva's Den
DLC tends to be pick and choose extra
content where you grab whatever specific
content appeals to you where expansion
packs will usually run you about 20 or
30 bucks for a huge chunk of content
some gamers get frustrated with DLC that
provides less content for a similar
price if you're a person who spends
money chances are you want to get good
value out of whatever you purchase
that's not always the case
with DLC recently unhappy feelings were
brought about when Evolved launched with
over a hundred and thirty bucks worth of
day one weapon skins and when Tiger
Woods PGA Tour 13 revealed that the
majority of its courses were hidden find
a paywall way back in the early days of
deals see the Elder Scrolls oblivion
offered a set of purely cosmetic horse
armor for two dollars fifty a move which
made a lot of people angry and which
spiraled into becoming the go-to name
for outrageous DLC offerings but there's
the vice-president Pete Hines later said
they learned a bunch of lessons from
that poor move saying it's not about the
amount of money it's about are you
giving them really good value for what
you're making them pay for we have to
make sure we're providing enough quality
for what you're paying for whatever
you're paying for so that the customer
feels satisfied that I got good value
for my money what all these examples and
many more have proved is that there are
good and bad ways to ask your fans to
spend more money on your game pay2win
strategies that instantly unlock things
a gamer would otherwise be working
toward a pretty unpopular expensive
cosmetics are also pretty unpopular
recently The Witcher 3 developers laid
out the thinking behind their plans for
DLC and expansions after those previous
examples it seems they could be on the
right track set a Projekt RED CEO masa
Nowitzki said quote first and foremost I
think the word DLC has become extremely
devalued any additional content is
called DLC whether it's one sword
awesome question
options or a full expansion pack I
really look at it differently the mini
DLC is the smaller bits and pieces and
we will never charge for those things
however if we do a big adventure say 15
or 20 hours long a very high production
value story extension to the game then
we will probably charge for that and set
a project are doing just that they're
providing 16 pieces of smaller DLC for
free which include things like extra
side missions costume changes and yes
even horse armor then they're charging
25 bucks for their expansion pass which
grants access to The Witcher threes two
expansion packs which they've said will
add up to about 30 hours of content
hopefully their strategy ends up being
as reasonable as it sounds game
publishers will always vary with how
much value for money they think they're
offering up with their DLC and expansion
packs so it may not always seem
reasonable that said it's been up to you
to decide what's worth your while as
crazy as it may sound some people are
totally up for paying 15 bucks to unlock
all the chests in Assassin's Creed unity
all the bonuses in Mortal Kombat X
otherwise those options wouldn't keep
existing other people don't care about
extra guns costumes or side quests if
they don't significantly affect the base
game and as good as Mass Effect 3 DLC
campaign missions work some people like
me decided that their time with Shepherd
was over as soon as they hit that blue
green or red light riddles end sequence
what kind of DLC and expansion packs do
you think are worth paying for
what's off-limits and what's been your
favorite let me know down in the
comments and I'll catch you again next
week